the hunt for the sixth person infected
with the brazilian variant of the virus
is moving
at a rapid pace such is the urgency of
identifying the person who forgot to put
their name and dress on the test
paperwork
that public health teams have even tried
tracing the kit
back through the postal system detective
work that's paying off
we've identified the batch of home test
kits in question
our search has narrowed from the whole
country down to
379 households in the southeast of
england and we're contacting each one
we're grateful that a number of
potential cases have come forward
following the call that we put out over
the weekend
so just how concerned should we be about
the p1
variant the first comprehensive study of
how the virus overwhelmed the city of
manaus and brazil
gives some clues first it spreads
more easily researchers from the uk and
brazil estimate that the variant is
between
1.4 and 2 times more transmissible
than previous versions of the virus
circulating in the city
second it evades the immune system for
every 100 people who develop covid19 in
the first wave last spring
between 25 and 61 were likely to be
re-infected third it's not
yet clear whether it causes more serious
infection
people who develop covid19 after the p1
variant started spreading in manaus
were between 10 and 80 percent more
likely to die
but the researchers can't be sure
whether this was because the virus was
more lethal
or because people struggled to get
medical care hospitals
ran out of oxygen because of demand the
key
question is what this means for the uk
for starters the scientists say just six
cases are unlikely to be enough to spark
an outbreak and secondly the p1 variant
may not have a
competitive edge over other viruses in
the uk
it has the same n501y mutation
as the kent variant both spread fast but
the brazilian variant shouldn't
overtake the existing dominant version
of the virus
now vaccines haven't yet been tested
against the brazilian virus
but scientists say that shouldn't slow
the roll out in the uk
bringing cases down to a low numbers
will give the test and trace system
a much better chance of identifying
people infected
with the new versions of the virus